you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman leeches org
and it's going to play a 5-2 game okay
before he five it is let's play like way
e let's try to hmm okay yeah he likes
this so do I like this d3 system so
what's the big idea here with Bishop c5
just getting it outside of the pawn
chain are you well let's grab him now
okay taking away from the center are you
alrighty well I'm going to play what
let's play Queen e2 right now yep
alright now may be threatening to take
on e5 let's see yeah okay so yeah I've
have some experience I did cover a game
recently way versus Magnus Carlsen
although no I'm mistaken way versus
David navara check that they played a
similar similar game where Bishop
captures Knight was played after the
Bishop move but not in reply to a six so
I think I'm up a move in this position
okay how can i maybe make use of that
fact that I'm maybe one move up I think
by now Black was castled so this is a
typical rerouting of the night oh I
still need to just get my knight working
let's go straight in for this in here
I'm a I'm keeping the option open to
Castle queenside and my knight I believe
belongs right here they're gonna go in
for a quick
Knight to e6 aren't they
okay well can I really do so much about
that maybe this is something worth
considering hmm and then here as well
this is five - right okay yes it is
[Music]
well I'm going to go with something
let's try a night see for spent a real
lot of time on that one
I'm expecting night to f8 to e6 okay
hang on not this night into f5 but
rather this one takes two steps for him
it takes three for him but I think he's
more important to have on f3 to watch
over d4 for when the night arrives on e6
I think I want to go in for this next it
could be kicked could certainly be
kicked to watch out for these two
squares when the night arrives on e6
I think they should go for that instead
of castles making use of f8 okay and
maybe hmm
would I be okay with the night arriving
on therefore let's see yeah I think g6
is gonna be strong to kick my night when
it arrives on their five let's go with
this on Bishop takes I'm taking with the
pawn to cover these squares they're
playing that that can't be right I'm
gonna open the position up huh
okay I could take the bishop and play d4
that's why I'm thinking that this wasn't
a good idea for black it's my
opportunity to take their bishop if I
don't play d4 now they may be placed
five do I play this right now or one
move later I want to play it right now
actually if takes they take with the
pond and then on d4 if I'm ever taking
they could take with the D pawn follow
now I could take the fish over and
should it's with Chuck not quite sure
how to take the pawn on d-day quit the
Queen I have a long-term idea now four
versus three healthy four versus
three on the kingside so should it get
stripped to a king and pawned specific
ending I like that might have a case of
opposite color bishops on Queen b4 I
have c3 to defend b2 I'm also taking
with the knight to avoid a pin so the
position has opened up in there Knight
it's still on the back rank I'm one move
away and now with the D file completely
opened I'm much more inclined to Castle
queenside two very good things are
accomplished now with queenside castling
King side and rook activity do not
always get that should I go straight in
for it let's get a move on ooh
this was another serious move to
consider oh well
they'd have for Queen here yeah I should
have considered Knight here that could
have been a dagger a dagger move forward
throw a punch prepare to double on the D
file I guess Queen e6 although the
bishop will struggle to get developed a
moment to maybe stop Queen side castles
rook here Bishop c5 we're going to be
castled on opposite wings hmm can I stop
them from castling
I don't know
could insert this check let's do that
they touch their Jeep on that's some
serious dark square weaknesses that can
maybe exploit okay maybe now they're
just not going to Castle you're moving
forward you're definitely moving forward
on Bishop e6 I believe I do this g3
Queen here that's it maybe quite alright
maybe I do you play b3 however I have to
be concerned about a4 do they have time
to do that
don't know c5 and then taking here would
be very greedy and they seem to be a fan
of that idea rook here threatens Bishop
takes pawn yeah let's play to a dark
square right here and I'm have
development on Queen takes pawn I have
Queen here they are not developed Queen
takes pawn I could take here as well
Bishop here in queenside castle I think
is a must these next two moves very
serious they're not doing that let's
just keep my EEP on Bishop is defended
Bishop here just gonna do that I'm
fearful of this pawn break if I play b3
instead so let's just get out of the way
King they're castling by hand you can't
do that though drops hh7 I have pressure
there let's just double up improve my
bishop position they're gonna go at me
with b5
that's the only thing would that would
force me to find some you know to force
me to be a bit more accurate with my
moves otherwise I could just play this a
bit on the slower side g4 h4 h5 yeah
maybe I do this anyhow meeting any
before I move with this
let's look more direct their king is on
the seventh rank they want a queen trade
I don't know way hmm let me let me
repeat once I'm gonna go to a different
spot with the Queen right here I want to
keep pressure on H it's good G foreign
g5 I have this h5 I'm doing this I'm
breaking down their dark squares that's
my idea
I want my bishop on this dog and I could
play Queen h6 Bishop h6 i could play g5
this is winning i'm just trying to find
a way to win let's start with the check
and then here get my bishop on this dog
and all as soon as possible let's do it
I have pressure on c7 as well keep
pressure here bishop here there
shouldn't be a defense well I guess
Queen f8 still but I'm gonna as soon as
I get my Bishop on f6 both rooks are
dead
this must be busted for black a bishop
on e5 no no Queen trade I'm on c7 Bishop
to e5 next chases the rook away from
defense bishop here I could already
think about rucksacks rook d7 I won't be
taking this pawn though looking for more
and this is going to net me a lot more I
believe there's no Bishop move with
Czech evening out some on the clock that
move I did not consider so that is so
not cool huh oh I could just take the
rook what a blind spot all right let's
open it up
I almost didn't do that unbelievable I
almost missed taking the rook I forgot
what my threat was okay we're gonna
insert this check and then take here or
[Music]
hang on hang on not the best what I'm
doing here but I'm up material now all
right let's just pile up on this Bishop
seems like a pretty clean approach pile
up on that bishop and that's it I could
take the time to recapture yep mass
exchanges incoming
I'm just winning material bishop moves
I'm getting rook yeah that should do it
hmm all right I guess they're gonna play
this one out some I'm up at rook now
though playing with increment already
grabbed up on a check this is a new
seventh rank the sixth rank that's where
there's a lot of pawns strayed down no
back rancors and they resigned okay yeah
I spent a lot of time in the opening on
that one yeah it was the wayi versus
David Navarro game that I was trying to
recall and note some differences between
our game in their game
I believe that a6 wasn't played in their
game I think it was night here d3 and
then after Bishop here light voluntarily
retakes not after this uh not after a 6
and after takes Knight here castles
Queen here night here so I think we had
I'm not certain but I believe we had
this position this was this excuse me
was the position in the way versus Dave
and Navarro game however in our game
black had the pawn on a six and was
uncalled everything else was the same so
we get to this position right here on on
a six in their own castled so that's why
I was taking so much time here because I
was trying to work out well I was trying
to find a way to make use of this fact
that black was essentially behind a move
I don't know if I really approached it
the right way but you know okay we go
with the knight on c4 this is a very
typical maneuver to get the knight in to
e6 not sure about my move here Bishop to
e3 maybe it is fine I would have taken
with the pawn just to cover these
squares there are very important squares
to watch over but I think I think black
would do that hun bishop here if I take
here and he'll soon return and get to
these two maybe I could hold off maybe
uh maybe this is even an idea you know
and on castles now I could think about
taking and then blasting up in the
center you know this exchange of my D
pawn for their upon results and they
healthy four versus three majority on
the Kings side this right here so this
is a long-term advantage to have
compared that with black who has an
unhealthy a group of four pawns versus
three which on their own cannot this
group of four versus my three cannot
on their own create a past pond where as
mine can sew this said this eventually
did happen in the game where we had the
e pawn exchange for my D pawn but uh
yeah he's trying to figure out some
difference there with being up a move
essentially so it's quite happy to see
that my fish of C Bishop d6 I don't
think the computer will be a fan of that
I'm thinking the knight should have
played into e6 take stakes let me throw
in the evaluation right now arrows are
on what is it saying right around here
wants it take suggest pawn takes yeah
I'll even popped up Knight takes but no
Knight here even physician here's
another thing if I'm trying to get into
the f5 square okay yeah this is what I
was considering but I I didn't like it
well they can't go straight in for that
because I'm a queen check no I don't
know about that I don't know if black
would really be a fan of going on
castles like this that h4 bishop here if
I went with let me say this much if
because this is a big moment where I
gave a lot of I believe this was the
move I spent a lot of time if I tried
night here 96 and night here so if I was
my knight gets kicked you know where
does he go so one thing that ran through
my mind which was if I play to g3 this
Knight f4 move if I'm ever capturing the
night look at this guy
it's having a tough day so I don't know
about this idea of jumping into f5 f5 is
not a reliable home be kicked different
if the pawns on g5 but yeah I always you
know to be concerned of you know the g6
move and I have to know
where will my nights next home be and I
didn't have a good answer to that so
that's why I didn't shoot right in for
this f5 square Bishop d6 and this is
where there is a change that's what I
thought it does like to go with d4 right
away the difference being if you take
they take with the pawn and now if
challenged any capture could be met with
the recapture of their C pond that has
been converted to a deep pond whereas
playing d4 first now I'm threatening to
acquire that long-term asset of having a
four versus three majority on the Kings
side by not being so quick to capture on
this d6 square so I went with the d4
take I took what well I did the
in-between move I guess I was a little
concerned about the bishop maybe running
away although I guess there isn't really
a great square can run away too if
Bishop c5 AB Knight takes c6 or that one
which is better waiting a piece yeah
let's not forget it soon as that Knight
moves there's this open diagonal yeah
let me even go back and reprogram myself
some because this f6 square there should
be the f6 move I've only really been
seeing it as okay defending e5 but let's
look at the downside open diagonal now
towards the King open diagonal towards
the King for when he has castled who's
like d4 permit Queen checks Knight moves
King Knight moves allow checks in this
direction okay noted just to kind of
have it in the back of my mind these are
some of the things I do so Castle
queenside yeah some believe I don't know
where some
some viewer I think at some point asked
me you know when is a good time to
Castle queenside you know it's so
popular at Castle kingside this would
certainly be a case where castling
queenside is good if you have if you can
castle a queen side and have your rook
on an open or even half open file it's
certainly worth a closer look
typically when you Castle queenside
you'll have to invest an additional
tempo to move the king over because this
is a this is a weak point you don't get
that when you Castle kingside you're
already watching over that furthest that
that rook upon but yeah Castle queenside
in cases I'll consider castling
queenside in cases where you have the
rook activity or and maybe even in some
rare cases where it is not yet an open D
file and but it can potentially open up
but yeah if it's already opened like
this one it's really crying out to be
played
so it's liking my position here it likes
the Queen h5 move I'm glad I spotted
that right around here I was considering
moves like rook c4 but that's that's
going a bit of stray when you're taking
a rook off of the only open file in a
position just to line up some tactic
yeah
don't know about rook to c4 it's also
running into this yeah so yeah I went
with green check and it's pretty serious
now for black yeah there there
improvement was right here not playing
Bishop d6 right here not playing Bishop
d6 but rather well it's going with the
capture but I don't really see anything
wrong with that
we're just getting the knight in to e6
and castling but I guess this was the
other move to go with Bishop here Bishop
f6 Knight e6
is an idea they are throwing a punch at
my knight
as the computers pointing out here on
this Bishop e6 move I could be
considering a break in the center now
black is a bit more behind in
development this would be another case I
would still look into castling queenside
because of these possibilities of
pushing opening up the the D file well
in both in both ways right potential
capture potential push exchange of the
deep on and seep on but yeah this was
another this was another approach 96
instead of Bishop to d6 in the game they
went to d6 and we had this break and I
have to be the preferred side here
development wise long term four versus
three on the kingside he's all tip in my
favor
he's both tip in my favor and yeah it's
just going to be a very tough defense
here because the dark squares are
completely broken down already it's
calling for the final crack at their
last
kingside pond who is on a dark square
what's the trick here on Queen takes
here rook there Bishop here huh computer
makes very quick use of those dark
squares and on takes here
that's pretty lethal yeah that's a
deadly move right there huh you know the
dark squares are broken down I went with
the modest f3 just defending e4 I guess
I could have been more direct but yeah
due to the pressure on this h7 pond
there's no contesting this file and
because you can't contest the file the
bishop and queen are both restricted to
babysitting the d7 square come to think
of it now I think on this green f8 move
I may have been able to play rook d7 mmm
it was something I should have at least
considered don't know that it's really
working out you know yeah there's
there's not going to be a defense well I
did pop up for a moment not so
convincing and unnecessary it's
unnecessary to go in for these
complications to to enter an imbalance
position when I could keep the keep the
balance in material well material but
just keep it where only I have the
advantage that would be unnecessary
unnecessary complications to go in for
that imbalance thought it better to
approach it like this another ePHI push
they should be here wow it's going off
the charts devaluation Queen f8 now it's
maybe a different story takes takes
King here isn't this even a move get the
Queen discovered checks okay yeah I
should have went it looked a bit more at
this pawn sack and one way to look at it
is if there was any fear in my mind of
oh you know it's a pawn loss well okay
should it even get to this point you
know opposite color bishops and maybe
you know that pawn isn't even so
relevant but of course my mentality
should be more so along the lines of
okay let's still play this position
where you're looking to attack we're not
quite at that point of obstacle or
Bishop ending me being down upon and I
could try and hold a hold it to a draw
but yeah I should have been looking more
into the e5 push is what I'm getting at
and you know it's just broken down from
here I definitely want to keep the
Queens on I almost missed Bishop takes
rook
I'm just forgot I was on the rook okay
and that's pretty much it getting the
material there what was the you know the
graph was that Bishop d6 move again
right here couldn't really do that
something else was needed takes 96 okay
well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below and I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you